herzlich willkommen zum theologischen
stammtisch ich begrüße sie aus dem sud
in basel
heute diskutieren wir über einen
zankapfel der liberalen gesellschaft
schlechthin nämlich über die
prostitution für die einen ist es
einfach das älteste gewerbe der welt und
gehört respektiert für die anderen ist
sie ein kolossaler missstand und hat
nichts zu tun mit freiheit sondern sehr
viel mehr mit zwang und ausbeutung
die frauenzentrale zürich hat diesen
sommer eine kampagne lanciert mit dem
ziel die freier in zukunft zu bestrafen
die frauenzentrale sagt prostitution ist
unwürdig wie man über diese themen
diskutieren kann und was ihr dazu denken
sollten das diskutiere ich nachher
gleich am philosophischen stammtisch
jetzt zuerst spreche ich mit andre
agassis präsidentin der frauenzentrale
zürich und hat diese kampagne lanciert
frau gißler prostitution abschaffen
warum also prostitution kann man nicht
abschaffen so wenig wie man kriege
abschaffen kann oder mord und totschlag
es geht einfach darum wie ist die
haltung der gesellschaft zu prostitution
und das sind wir von der frauenzentrale
zürich der auffassung dass in der
prostitution die frauen zur ware
degradiert werden wie ein konsumgut
behandelt werden mittlerweile sogar zu
dumpingpreisen aber ihr ziel ist schon
dass prostitution doch vielleicht
irgendwann nicht mehr geben würde
das ist natürlich die vision aber wir
sind realistisch ich denke in der
schweiz ist es wichtig dass man die
diskussion zustande kommt wie was halten
wie gehen wir mit der prostitution um
sie plädieren für das sogenannte
schwedische modell als eben bestrafen
der freiherr und nicht bestrafung der
prostituierten dieses modellen gibt es
seit 20 jahren in schweden norwegen
frankreich finnland und viele andere
länder sind nachgezogen und haben dieses
modell auch eingeführt nun werden ja die
folgen dieses modells kontrovers
beurteilt als die international zum
beispiel aber auch der die farm schweiz
äußern sich kritisch
wie gehen sie mit dieser kritik um
wir tun einfach immer so wie wenn
prostitution bei uns so in einem
geordneten geschützten rahmen ablaufen
würde und das ist einfach nicht so wie
wir schauen nach deutschland wo man ja
sie 2002 wurde ein prostitutionsgesetz
eingeführt und das ziel war die frauen
besser zu schützen dass sie sich
anmelden können sozial versichern können
und das war das resultat die arbeits und
lebensbedingungen der frauen haben sich
massiv verschlechtert
es ist zudem ein bordell in
flatrate-bordellen gekommen und da kommt
einem dann die rubrik plüschige idylle
rasend schnell abhanden
bei uns ist auch beatrice benninger sie
ist geschäftsführerin der stadt vision
in zürich und sie betreiben eine
anlaufstelle eine beratungsstelle für
prostituierte
sie sind kritisch gegenüber der kampagne
der frauenzentrale warum kritisch
gegenüber der kampagne aber insbesondere
auch gegenüber dem schweden modell das
schweden modell ist eine mogelpackung
man möchte dass es weniger prostitution
gibt um das zu erreichen kriminalisiert
man die freie
das mag gut gemeint sein aber wie man so
schön sagt das gegenteil von gut ist gut
gemeint und in schweden ist die
datenlage sehr umstritten die einen
sagen es habe wirklich viel bewirkt es
gebe weniger freie andere sagen das
gegenteil
fakt ist man wollte mehr sicherheit für
die frauen realität man hat das
gegenteil erreicht
sie sagen auch dass eines der probleme
sei dass die kampagne und eben auch das
schwedische modell frauen prostituierte
als opfer abständen werde genau und
dahin keine opfer sie das sind nicht per
se opfern und die frauen sehen sich auch
nicht außer natürlich wenn man im
bereich zwangsprostitution thematisiert
da ist
ist eine andere thematik aber ganz
grundsätzlich von einem berufsgruppe
oder von einer gruppe mit einer
tätigkeit einfach zu sagen über deren
köpfe weg sie seien allesamt opfer
das stört mich gewaltig sind für sie
prostituierte opfer letztlich geht es um
ausbeutungsverhältnisse und einen
missstand und das kiten wir eigentlich
ohren und ich denke es geht nicht nur um
die individuelle ebene sondern es geht
eben auch um die gesellschaftspolitische
ebene es geht eben darum dass wir das
system prostitution kritisch
hinterfragen müssen und um dieses system
prostitution wird es jetzt gleich gehen
am philosophischen stammtisch ich bin
sehr gespannt auf die diskussion hier
bei uns ihnen schon einmal herzlichen
dank
und ich freue mich sehr auf die
diskussion mit meinen gästen heute abend
salome bald ist bei uns ist
prostituierte und philosophin peter
schaber professor für philosophie am
ethik zentrum der universität zürich
sandra konrad psychologin und
psychotherapeutin und dominik künzel
feministischer philosoph und
privatdozent für philosophie an der
universität zürich
herzlich willkommen
frau baut ist die diskussion über an
prostitution verbot ärgert sie warum
also erstmal freue ich mich hier vor
allem weil ich eingeladen worden bin ist
meine alte talkshow und ich bin dankbar
dass ich hier sprechen darf wir sind
dankbar dass alle sind ich habe keine
erwartungen an diese sendung ich habe
die erwartung dass diese sendung die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
unterstützt und die liberale
gesellschaft er für alle andern ihrem
tisch oder im raum
es ist hier eine folgende diskussion da
geht es um sachthemen für mich ist das
nicht so bei keinem von ihnen ist hier
in frage gestellt ob er von seinem beruf
weiterhin leben darf auf seine existenz
abgeschafft werden so gar nicht bei mir
schon das ist der feine unterschied
und ich entschuldige mich im voraus wenn
ich vielleicht später die fassung
verliere oder ausrasten könnte denn es
ist nun mal keine freie diskussion ist
es so als würde man über das thema ob
man menschen darstellen darf ist maler
mit einer runde diskutieren die zur
hälfte aus ecolog lasten gesteht und
zwar nicht einfach rein hypothetisch
sondern in zeiten des bilder sturms ich
diskutiere ja also nicht ergebnisoffen
darüber habe ich meine grundrechte
behalten darf ich bin hier um zu kämpfen
so lange ich noch kann und deswegen
ärgert sie auch die debatte über ein
verbot genau zu ihrer frage es wäre ich
gefalle das wäre gefährlich und zwar
nicht nur für mich sondern für alle hier
wenn man einmal anfängt weil man etwas
kritisieren möchte oder wenn das
christus ist verständlich kritisiert man
darf sehr viel darüber sagen muss auch
ich damit gar nicht beschäftigen muss
auch das nicht konsumieren und natürlich
sollten auch keine prostituierte werden
müssen um gottes willen aber jeder auch
weil sich dafür nicht interessiert
sollte dafür sein dass sie prinzipiell
geben darf denn wenn wir dieses gebot
der liberalen gesellschaft die freiheit
der andersdenkenden die wir mühsam in
der aufklärung erworben haben fallen
lassen dann können auch die freiheit der
lehre die freiheit
das schnell ist muss die freiheit von
psychologie als nächstes unter den
hammer kommt die prostitution das
sozusagen das kanarienvögeln in der
kohlemine der meinungsfreiheit
wenn gut sind schon ganz viele themen
auf den tisch
herr künzli was denken sie sind ein
feministischer philosoph was sagen sie
dazu
jack und zunächst denke ich natürlich
dass wir auf jeden fall sagt diskutieren
müssen
ich bin auch bereit das zu diskutieren
gleichzeitig denke ich auch dass es aus
der perspektive jetzt der philosophie
nicht nur am stammtisch aber vielleicht
besonders am stammtisch sieht man es gut
ziemlich vermessen wäre jetzt direkt
über die frage einer gesetzesänderung zu
sprechen also ich kann euch weniger
jetzt sagen ja ich bin absolut dafür
oder dagegen
ich bin sicher der ansicht dass
prostitution morales sehr problematisch
ist und könnte würde mir auch eine
gesellschaft vorstellen der das nicht
gibt ich glaube aber daraus folgt
überhaupt nicht dass ein verbot im
moment unter den gegebenen umständen
richtige weg ist weil wenn die
betroffenen leiden und wenn über ihre
köpfe hinweg entschieden wird dann kann
das trotzdem
also das heißt wir können zum beispiel
der ansicht seien prostitution an sich
ist keine gute sache eine welt ohne
prostitution wäre besser dennoch kann
ein verbot problematik einer welt es
gibt nur eine welt genau es ist
sozusagen die these es wird sowieso
immer prostitution geben aber lassen sie
uns noch kurz bei der these bleiben
eine welt mit oder ohne position der
besser oder schlechter herrsche aber wie
sehen sie das wäre eine welt ohne
prostitution besser also ich würd mal
ganz allgemein sagen ich habe eine
vision dass eine wünschenswerte welt
stadien bestehen würde das die rechte
die in den menschenrechts dekoration
festgehalten werden von allen menschen
geschützt und geachtet werden und das
gab ich gilt auch für prostituierte
es ist wichtig dass deren rechte die ihm
häufig verletzt werden
zwangsprostitution wurde schon erwähnt
dass dieser rechte geschützt werden und
das scheint wichtiger zu sein und eine
solche welt wird ich meinen
die anzustreben ist respekt vor den
rechten
wir werden im detail auf dieser rechte
zu sprechen kommen aber die antwort wäre
eine bessere welt wenn sie jetzt
trotzdem sicher dass wir die bessere
welt wenn wenn wenn es diese missbrauchs
phänomene die es zweifelsohne gibt wenn
denen wir noch reden werden
ausbeutung wurde gesagt wurde erwähnt
schon zwangsprostitution oder während
fans teenie damit sagen sie ja
eigentlich es gibt prostitution ohne
zwang die frau conrad haben ein buch
geschrieben das beherrschte geschlecht
darin gibt es ein kapitel über
prostitution das beginnen sie mit dem
märchen von pretty woman und irma la
douce wenn sie sagen wunderbare
geschichten da kommt ein begüterter
wunderschöner man und rettet das mädchen
aus der gosse aber sie sagen märchen
gibt es nicht ja also und diese märchen
helfen uns als gesellschaft dass wir die
dunklen seiten der prostitution ganz
schön verleugnen und auch verdrängen
können
wir sehen in talkshows üblicherweise
keine frauen die gerade von ihren
zuhältern zusammengeschlagen und wir
sehen in talkshows keine schwer
drogenabhängigen jungen mädchen die für
10 euro ohne kondom oralverkehr machen
wir sehen in talkshows keine
osteuropäischen analphabetinnen die
hierher kommen und von menschenhändlern
wirklich jede woche in ein unterschieden
ein anderes modell in deutschland oder
europa verschleppt werden das alles
sehen wir nicht und wir sehen eine
glamourwelt der prostitution die können
wir uns auch wunderbar ins wohnzimmer
holen indem wir in der netflix serie
angucken und wir denken ach das ist so
schön liebe bereit zu sein das ist alles
in ordnung die welt ist in ordnung und
wir verleugnen
die realität für eine mehrheit von
prostituierten die eben durch ausbeutung
gewalt und auch kriminalität geprägt ist
sie schüttelt den kopf
was ihr da beschreiben ist es kriminell
das verboten ist sollte auch verfolgt
werden
das stört mich genauso wie sie denn die
gesetze die es bereits gibt nicht
eingehalten werden
also genauso gut müsste man eigentlich
baugewerbe und die landwirtschaft
verbieten weil da ist der anteil von
arbeitssklaven sehr viel höher als in
der prostitution und wenn er sich jetzt
verteidigen muss mit meinem legalen job
wo ich für bessere arbeitsbedingungen
kämpfen
und sie meinen dass man den frauen denen
es schlecht geht in dem job dadurch
hilft indem man ihnen auch noch die
legale einkommens möglichkeit verwehrt
sodass keine andere wahl treffen die sie
noch weniger treffer wurden schuldigen
die haupt einstiegs kriterien in die
prostitution sind armut und zwar bei mir
war es auch mangelndes einkommen richtig
aber ich glaube die haupt einsteigen in
jeden job sind zu wenig geld und wir
müssen alle geld verdienen also es gibt
immer noch die möglichkeit sich zu
entscheiden und da wo es die möglichkeit
nicht gibt das ist zwang und der ist
verboten
ich ziehe mir glaube ich beim punkt wo
wir uns überlegen müssen kann mir denn
die shops vergleichen können wir das ja
und nein also ich glaube wird jetzt von
mir als als feministisch und philosophen
erwartet dass ich sage erwarten
vielleicht vielleicht würde ich zuerst
mal sagen nicht unbedingt weil es gibt
auch in anh tatsächlich natürlich auch
in anderen jobs gibt wie sexismus und
ausbeutung nicht alle jobs sind super
also wenn es nicht ein per se eine
verteidigung der prostitution wenn wir
sagen das ist wie andere jobs aber
gleichzeitig glaube ich natürlich auch
dass es dass es nicht wie andere jobs
ist also dass sich das als intrigante
unterscheidet und ich meine da jetzt ich
meine gar nicht unbedingt jetzt in
erster linie aus meiner perspektive die
tatsache dass das tor 6 im spiel ist
oder so sondern ich glaube schon dass
wir das sonst könnte habe ich glaube
schon dass bei prostitution
machtverhältnisse und ungerechte
strukturen die sonst in der gesellschaft
vorherrschend sind auf eine besonders
deutliche art manifestiert werden und
bestärkt werden und und am leben
erhalten und gestützt werden
tschuldigung ich glaube wir können den
körper nicht ausnehmen aus der gleichung
weil wenn wir das mit anderen
tätigkeiten vergleichen wir verkaufen
unsere arbeitskraft und in der
prostitution werden körper verkauft
genauer gesagt körperöffnungen und das
ist etwas das wir sagen ja häufig
prostitutions befürworter die sagen es
ist doch genau das gleiche und ich bitte
jetzt wirklich jeden dazu hört sich das
einmal vorzustellen männer und frauen
ist es ein unterschied ob ich meine
wegen irgendwas putze oder wenn ich
meinen körper zur verfügung stelle und
wenn ich mal anna oder vaginal und ich
bitte auch die männer jetzt kurz sich
das vorzustoßen noch deutlich weniger
spaß
vor allem sei all das sagen sie ist ein
für eine vielzahl für die mehrheit der
prostituierten ist es eine entwürdigende
tätigkeit eine tätigkeit in der sie zum
objekt gemacht wenn und in der sie sehr
viel gewalt erwachsen entschuldige
essens ich habe meine körperöffnung alle
noch zumindest als ich eben nachgeschaut
hat waren sie noch da auch mein körper
ist kein wir sind doch hier alle
marxistisch gebildet als philosophen ich
meine der unterstützung von einer ware
und einer dienstleistung oder einer ware
und einem kapital das ist doch allen
klar
und wenn ich eine wahre bin weil ich ein
dienstleistungen anbiete bei der ich
übrigens füße schon geistig sehr präsent
sein muss um sie gut zu machen und mich
nicht abkapseln kann das wär ja leicht
dann kann man doch nicht sagen dass ein
bauarbeiter der schwer trägt den körper
nicht verkauft oder wäre es denn besser
als künstler seine seele zu verkaufen
als als denker seine gedanken sein
gehirn seine aufmerksamkeit wir leben in
einer gesellschaft wo es waren förmigen
austausch gibt das ist alles nicht schön
aber ich stehe dass das thema ist moora
also ich wäre gerne mal fragen der ganz
viel zum thema instrumentalisierung und
menschenwürde gearbeitet hat was heißt
es denn den körper zu einer ware zu
machen wann benutzt man eine frau oder
einen mann also zunächst mal wenn wir
von ware reden reden wir von etwas was
einen preis hat
es wird ja oft gesagt der position wo
immer man klebt den frauen ein
preisschild krieg halte ich auch geld
also bescheiden zwischen zwischen dem
verkauf seiner arbeitskraft und die
biene oder wie sie oft auch verausgabung
körperlich körperliche leistung dass das
das gehört ja verschieden orten dazu und
zu sagen eine person ist eine wahre das
würde heißen dass man die person
verkaufen kann oder kaufen kann das
trifft aber jetzt auf position auch
nicht so zu dass natürlich körperliche
dass das das ist eine andere tätigkeit
ist als beispielsweise das putzen
es ist eine andere tätigkeit es wieder
andere tätigkeiten die frage ist ist
etwas grundsätzlich danach unzulässig
das ist natürlich noch nicht damit
bestimmt dass man sagt es ist was
anderes
die bestimmung dass sich jemand als
ganze person verkauft stimmt nicht das
ist dass das wäre in der tat gesetzt
dann wäre das den gegeben sklaverei zu
also doch einmal das wahre hatten preis
das und das heißt es gibt ja menschen
die kamera kaufen nicht verkaufen das
erreichen der hauptwohnung prostitution
degradiert die frau zur ware dann werden
sie auch wieder so sagen danke
diese these stimmt nicht übrigens kann
ich mir vorstellen dass verschiedene
wenn ich das wenn ich das sagen dass
verschiedene formen das auszuführen
degradieren sind und entwürdigend das
will ich gar nicht bestreiten das hängt
sehr stark davon ab ob das per sie damit
zu tun hat dass man sexuelle
dienstleistungen verkauft dass man da so
behauptet das als solches schon
entwürdigen da bin ich mir nicht so
sicher habe ich meine zweifel
ich bin jetzt bei der reinen
instrumentalisierungen auch nicht so
sicher ob man das dann abgrenzen kann
von anderen tätigkeiten wo man auf
vollen körpereinsatz leistet oder eben
geistig dass ich ich hätte es glaube ich
ähnlich was ich wo ich denn also ähnlich
verbaut ist ja und ja also ich denke
jetzt einfach nur die tatsache wie man
seinen körper instrumentalisiert ich
sehe dass es da viele fälle gibt und bei
denen man natürlich das sagen würde
aber ob das jetzt auf alle fälle
zutrifft wie ich bin ich sicher ich sehe
das problem wie gesagt er im kontext mit
anderen mitmacht beziehungen zwischen
männern und frauen in der gesellschaft
und in dem kontext glaube ich schon dass
dass es so was gibt wie sexuelle
autonomie und der geben wir einen
bestimmten wert
das geben wir offensichtlich in vielen
vielen kontexten zum beispiel bei
sexueller belästigung am arbeitsplatz
das werden wir natürlich nicht richtige
wollen die leute davor schützen
und ich denke schon dass es sinn macht
das zu schützen dass man sagt das ist
was besonderes und das ist nicht ohne
weiteres vergleichbar mit anderen formen
heftig wird in ich merke ich hängen noch
an einem punkten vorhergesagt
sie müssen so präsent sein wenn sie ihre
tätigkeit machen und wir wissen ja aus
den studien und wir wissen auch von
prostituierten die ausgestiegen sind wie
sehr sie spalten müssen wir wissen wie
hoch die was heißt spalten heißt das in
dem moment wenn diese tätigkeit
ausgeführt wird ist dass die frauen sich
abspalten müssen von dieser situation
von ihren emotionen und das bedeutet
dass sie sich immer weiter von sich und
von ihren emotionen entfremden und es
wird ebenso vielen folge störungen viele
frauen in der prostitution sind
traumatisiert
es gibt ja auch die erfahrung von
prostituierten selber die das erzählen
das geht ja viele therapeuten und
therapeutinnen die mit prostituierten
arbeiten und die genau das erzählen es
gibt depressionen es geht
traumatisierung es gibt angst störung
viele prostituierte können diese
tätigkeit nur überstehen in dem sie sich
betäuben indem sie sich mit all der
gelegenheit betäuben wusste was ich auch
noch sagen möchte wir versuchen
künstlich eine trennung herbeizuführen
zwischen zwangsprostitution und
freiwilliger prostitution aber die
existente auf diesem markt gar nicht
leide auch die existiert sehr wohl sehr
wohl und dass die spaltung angeht wenn
ich das ausführen da ich meine ich finde
es interessant dass die these das habe
ich auch gelesen was ich ja also ich
erlebe einig dass ich mich bei meinen
dates mit meinen kunden ich nenne sie
nicht freier das würde sie verletzten
sich übrigens auch endlich einig sehr
sehr auf jemanden einlassen muss ist es
ähnlich wahrscheinlich für das was in
der therapie machen ich muss
herausfinden was für dieser mensch und
wenn ich mich da abkapseln würde dann
würde ich das wahrscheinlich nicht sehr
gut machen aber trotzdem wissen wir
natürlich
was ist dieses abspielt das weiß jeder
weil das auch im privatleben vorkommt es
gibt eine wunderbare literarische
referenz dazu bei tristram shandy
verloren stern wo beschreiben wird dass
bayer derzeit erzeugung seine mutter den
vater daran erinnerte dass er vergessen
aufzuziehen und was das bedeutet dass
sie an die uhrzeit dachte wir in diesem
heiligen moment das kennen wir alle oder
dass man als frau und seinen kopf
schüttel denkt andererseits ist
natürlich auch eine form der abspaltung
jetzt vielleicht weniger banales dass
man dass man sich im rausch verliert
auch da kann man sagen dass man sich von
seinem in seiner umgebung löst und
eintaucht nur ich glaube dass gerade in
prostitution des am wenigsten der fall
sein kann weil man wenn man die
kontrolle über die sache behalten da ist
immer die arbeit gut ausführen möchte
wird trotzdem auch mal aufzeigen wie
groß die bandbreite sozusagen ist sie
haben jetzt das stichwort
zwangsprostitution genannt die frau bald
wissen sie natürlich wie am anderen ende
ist sozusagen der fahnenstange wenn man
so will also sie verlangen oder erhalten
gemäß ihrer websites für acht stunden
2000 euro stimmt ein paar straßen weiter
vor steuern wie die nehmen 20 euro für
ein blowjob ja das ist furchtbar und ich
finde auch dass es wichtig wäre
ich bin deswegen auch in dem
berufsverband sexarbeit also best ev
eingetreten weil ich finde da muss
wirklich arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
ich würde gern diesen frauen erklären
ihr müsst euch teurer verkaufen ist
natürlich schwierig weil sie oft gar
nicht die wahl haben aber warum
eigentlich für die im internet-zeitalter
und sowas wie solidarität arbeiterrechte
wurden auch den arbeitern zwanzigsten
jahrhundert nicht geschenkt und wenn wir
wirklich dafür kämpfen wollen dass die
arbeitsbedingungen unserer kollegen mit
denen ich mich durchaus identifizieren
auch wenn ich ihr leben ich weiß ja auch
mal einem bordell im modell meines
vertrauens aber auch noch da weiß ich
dass auch um legale bordell gibt es
immer diese schwierigkeiten wie kann man
dafür sorgen dass man als frau das
selbstbestimmt und deswegen habe ich
auch meinen eigenen laden gegründet weil
auch im legalen bereich ist natürlich
probleme aber die kann man nur dann
lösen werden wir die legalität haben
wenn es uns nicht verboten wird
denn das was ich jetzt mache das kann
ich mit dem gesetz nicht mehr tun dann
könnte ich das noch heimlich machen bzw
die meine kolleginnen wir würden unseren
unseren klub unsere website wir würden
das verlieren als würde uns einfach
dafür bestrafen
abgesehen davon ist es so als würde man
sagen wenn man wie frei
er bestraft danke zu sagen wir wollen
zum film eine buchdruck sagen wir wollen
dem buch wirklich verbieten aber über
all das lesen von büchern verbieten also
ein sich ja völlig klar nicht alle
frauen prostituieren sich freiwillig um
was genau die aus prostituierte
gearbeitet hat die setz dich heute als
aktivistin gegen prostitution ein und
wir hören ihr kurz zu das zweite ist
dass durch die legalisierung
prostitution gesellschaftsfähiger
geworden ist also das bedeutet dass mit
dem freier sein mit dem freier da seien
auch kein stigma verbunden ist die
überlegenheit gehe ich mir nach der
partie noch ein döner kaufen oder eine
prostituierte und dadurch ist die
nachfrage gestiegen weil ja irgendwie
alle denken das ist normal sich eine
frau zu kaufen und das angebot wird
befriedigt vor allem durch
zwangsprostitution und menschenhandel
weil so viele prostituierte die das
freiwillig machen gibt es eben nicht
prostitution ist ja auch klassisch also
sind eben ganz oft arme frauen die das
machen
prostitution ist total rassistisch es
sind eben selten weiße wohlstand damen
wie das machen und die wenigen männer
die es gibt in der prostitution
befriedigen ja auch dem markt ein
höherer männer glastisch und rassistisch
davon sicher wieso machen diese frauen
dass und wie kommt eigentlich zu dieser
stigmatisierung dann nachher auch ja ich
glaube das sind natürlich zwei
unterschiedliche zwei unterschiedliche
fragen warum die frauen das machen ich
glaube das haben wir so ein bisschen
angesprochen
da gibt es vielleicht diese die sind
freiwillige kites begriff der eine rolle
spielt und dann bei einer großen zahl
ist es wahrscheinlich nicht direkt zwang
das gibt es auch natürlich dann ja auch
angesprochen
es gibt aber so ausbeutungsverhältnisse
natürlich auch wo die dann wo wir eigene
moralische argumente wieder anbringen
könnten die sich nicht auf zwang
beziehen sondern auf ausbeutung und ich
habe da immer so oder ich bin so
gespalten einerseits denke ich dass kann
eine möglichkeit und tugend der
philosophie dass man dass man
abstrahieren kann und sagen kann wir
unterhalten uns nur mal lieber komplett
freiwillige prostitution und
abmarschieren von allen realen
bedingungen und das muss ja auch möglich
sein
anderseits ist es sehr problematisch
weil ich natürlich auch der meinung
das in die realität problematisch ist
bis zur stigmatisierung kommt das hat
mir einigermaßen klar oder wenn man sich
das gesellschaftlich überlegt hat man
natürlich ein riesengroßes interesse
daran die diese frauen auch abzuwerten
damit wir natürlich auch gerechtfertigt
was man tut also wenn wenn eine
gesellschaft seit hunderten von jahren
sagt diese frauen sind was nicht
schmutzig und unmoralisch und vielleicht
sogar kriminell
dann ist es natürlich viel einfacher
dann im umgang mit diesen frauen das zu
tun was getan wenn wir sie weghaben will
sie aber nicht mehr sehen muss genau
betont ja im grunde genommen eine form
der prostitution in der es darum geht
aus gründen der armut sich zu
profitieren ist das auch eine form von
zwang her schauer
das hängt vom einzelfall ab dass das
kann sein aber darf ich noch etwas sagen
zu dem zudem stigmatisierung problem ich
möchte noch eine frage einfach in die
runde werfen
man kann sich ja auch die frage stellen
wieso ist eigentlich dieses gewerbe von
so viel missbrauch besetzt wie so kommt
es dazu dass es soviel
zwangsprostitution werden nicht eben
klein aber wieso muss nur das ich glaube
weil natürlich die leute glaubten viele
leute glauben dass man sich da alles
erlauben kann mit diesen menschen oben
gehen kann
die verachtung enorm ist und ich glaube
das ist ganz wichtig wäre dass man nicht
weiter zur stigmatisierung beiträgt und
zwar genau deshalb weil er natürlich es
noch verstärkt und ich möchte darauf
hinweisen bevor ich die frage beantworte
es dass das es gibt ein ganz sinnvollen
bericht die man lesen kann von amnesty
internation vor zwei jahren auf der
homepage nachzulesen der genau diesen
zusammen nach außen darstellt der sagt
stigmatisierung die gefördert wird durch
irgendwelche formen von kriminalisierung
dient überhaupt niemanden im gegenteil
setzt wie sie es setzt diese menschen
noch viel stärker der gewalt und der
ausbeutung aus und das wollte ich nicht
einfach kontingent das war nicht in
einen schwedischen kunden sind und dem
kunden aus ländern wo das verbot sind
sie sind anders in den ländern wo das
verboten ist und wo es ein
gesellschaftliches klima gibt dass
prostitution irgendwas schlimmes ist die
verhalten sich anders diesen
gleichzeitig irgendwie verklemmter aber
anders das haben sie auch schon gern sie
überschritten ist für sie bewusst seine
straftat und die sind übergriffig und
also bleibt das deutlich unterschätzt
wissen kunden aus schweden
oder norwegen island und konnten aus der
schweiz sehr mag finde es ganz
interessant weil ich habe hier im rahmen
meines buches sehr viel recherchiert
unter anderem war ich auf freier fuhren
also auf internet frei erfuhren und das
ausmaß der menschenverachtung ist
wirklich unfassbar
und da sehen wir nämlich diese tendenz
von männern die prostituierte aussuchen
die das gefühl haben das ist ich zahle
jetzt ein paar euro und diese frau muss
in dieser zeit genau das machen was ich
mir vorstelle
und wenn sie es nicht tut und was auch
passiert und das hat was mit der
stigmatisierung zu tun die die männer
stigmatisieren und entwerfen die frauen
war je mehr sie die frauen entwerten
desto weniger müssen sie über ihr
eigenes würdeloses und unethisches
verhalten nachdenken
ist es denn zwangsläufig unethisch das
ist mir jetzt immer noch nicht klar
also ich würde einfach sagen dass
stimmen meter stigmatisierung und das
müsste man stoppen man sollte sicher
nicht fördern
aber das bedeutet nicht dass man die
institution der prostitution ob
moralisch in ordnung finden muss
es ist was als solches nicht in ordnung
wenn jemand bereit ist seinen körper
gegen geld zur verfügung zu stellen
dann trägt man zu stigmatisierung
klarerweise weil man sagt man nicht die
zwangsprostitution ist green sondern es
ist halt schon etwas nicht in ordnung
wenn jemand dazu bereit
er muss niemand irgendetwas zu ihr seid
echt weiß es nicht besser
verbaut ist gespräche gleich über die
freiwilligkeit ihren die noch kurz was
frau conrad sagen jetzt habe ich gerade
leider den faden fall und ich wollte
sagen es ging darum ob das der zu
stigmatisierung beiträgt wenn man
sozusagen sagt es ist etwas verkehrt
daran genau und das für mich der
blickwinkel nicht in ordnung ich finde
wir sollten weniger über frauen in der
prostitution diskutieren und wir tun wir
hier potenzieren diese minimale freiheit
und minimale freiwilligkeit die eine
minderheit von frauen wie sie vielleicht
haben
lassen sie mich mit dem ausland aber wir
sprechen viel zu wenig über die
verantwortung und über die
freiwilligkeit und über die freiheit von
männern
ich weiß nicht wie es in der schweiz ist
in deutschland geht jeder fünfte mann
schätzt man regelmäßig zu prostitution
der schweiz dasselbe wie man geht davon
aus jeder fünfte schweizer einmal pro
jahr und ich finde da auf soll darüber
sollten wir vielmehr sprechen was ist
das dass männer immer noch dieses
historische recht haben das gesetzlich
verbriefte recht haben dass sie frauen
kaufen dürfen dass sie frauen zum objekt
machen dürfen das ist die freiheit in
der wir leben werden also wieder auf
jedoch verwischen fast exakt sein weil
ihre these jetzt frau conrad ist ja es
geht immer noch darum männer dürfen
frauen kaufen und das hat er ja vorhin
zurückgewiesen sie haben gesagt nicht
unter jedem umstand ist prostitution
einkaufen der frau
das heißt es geht immer darum wie wir
dieses gewerbe diesen akt sozusagen
interpretieren aber verstehen wenn sie
leider alles menschen radio lässt wenn
es wirklich der verkauf am körper ist
und sie meinen dass es jeder fünfte
schweizer beteiligt sich an einem
menschen halte geschäft was strafbar ist
und die polizei kannte sie verfolgen
dann ist das wirklich eine sehr
beunruhigende these ich meine sehr rege
rechtsstaats gefährden wenn man sich
dass ich also wenn ich ihnen glauben
schenken darf dass die exekutive in der
schweiz oder in anderen vergleichbaren
ländern de facto nicht funktioniert wenn
das war ein moment wieder männer
römische verbot sprechen ja nur über die
frage ist es moralisch in ordnung
juristisch darf man das in ein
juristisch darf man keinen
menschenhandel unterstützen man darf
juristisch und jemandem schlafen oder
niemanden dass ich nicht beteiligen an
geschäften wo man werde nicht wissen
kann dass das opfer von menschenhandel
sind und man darf auch nicht als
menschenhändler menschen kaufen das ist
verboten
also alles was an der prostitution
abscheu erregend kriminelles was mir
übrigens genauso schadet denn dieses
bild wird ja auch auf die illegalen
prostituierten projiziert übrigens auch
von kunden also ich krieg das im
niedriglohnbereich als ich noch im
bordell gearbeitet halbrechter schon mit
ja und auch von kolleginnen und das ist
nichts was mir gefällt meinetwegen also
müsste es das wirklich nicht geben es
wäre wirklich uns allen geholfen wenn es
das nicht gäbe nur man muss doch
unterscheiden zwischen der frau die sich
entscheidet ist jetzt lieber im boden
sechs stunden und verdiene doppelt so
viel wie im monat an der aldi kasse
verdienen würde lassen sie mich mal in
diesem moment eine ein zitat von ihnen
bringt aus seiner kolumne sie haben eine
kolumne in der welt und sie schreiben da
ist kann durchaus eine wahl sein lieber
für 20 euro zehn minuten oralverkehr
anzubieten anstatt für dieselben 20 euro
an ganzen tag in einem fast food
restaurant zu putzen solche
entscheidungen haben die in einer
liberalen gesellschaft zu respektieren
auch wenn sie uns nicht gefallen
zugegeben auch noch auf sexuell
belästigt werden aber das nur noch haben
wir das zu respektieren
frau conrad theoretisch ja und aber was
ich ihm eigentlich keine anfrage
theoretisch ja praktisch nein denn wir
reden wieder über freiheit von frauen
wir reden nicht über die freiheit reden
wenn unsere anleitung wie und frauen
ich finde ja ich glaube das ist man muss
dann zwei dinge auseinander nehmen dann
geht es besser ich glaube dass ich kein
problem eine einzelperson zu
respektieren in dem was sie tut und ihre
entscheidungen und sie nicht
stigmatisieren und zu denken
ich habe verständnis nur verständnis in
einer bestimmten situation wenn jemand
das macht sondern ich mach nicht mal
einen moralischen vorwurf einer
einzelnen person die das macht und
gleichzeitig zu sagen
die struktur dahinter ist ist sexistisch
die das stern ist die sexistische weil
weil wir weil sie ein modell stützt dass
wir in vielen aspekten unserer
gesellschaft auch finde nämlich ein
ungerechtes modell frauen gegenüber
was ich meine ist oder die das modell
ist grob und so hat man das mittel hatte
auch wirklich gerechtfertigt es so dass
dieses dampfkessel modell menschliche
bedürfnisse steigern in den wänden und
auf vielen einem dampfkessel irgendwann
muss man das ventil drücken und dann ist
wieder für eine weile gut und in diesem
modell bedeutet dass dann das nach
diesen bedürfnissen die spielregeln
definiert werden nach denen sich jeder
sexualität die frauen zu richten haben
und ich sehe das dann tatsächlich als
wirklich ein zahnrad und zu vielen
anderen in einer großen maschine eben
nicht die befugnis tisch ist zb wenn ich
bin gegen das jahr lehrreich und
richtigen 16 17 18 jährige
schülerinnen und schüler wenn wenn eine
16 jährige junge frau in einer beziehung
kommt und nach zwei monaten wo der
freund geduldig wartet das gefühl hat
jetzt schuldet sie ihn 6 oder wenn sie
dann sex hat und sie fragt sich was man
da macht und sie richtet sich nach krebs
und der mainstream pornografie oder wenn
sie später auf einem date geht und der
mann lädt sie zu einem teuren nach
dessen ein und bezahlt hier drei gläser
wein und dann hat sie das gefühl jetzt
muss ich ja vielleicht auch mit dem sex
haben und wenn dann nicht an spätestens
wenn sich auch noch mit ihm die treppe
hochgegangen ist aus einer wohnung in
einem café hat oder werden im zuge der
mito bewegung hier in der schweiz
argumente gesagt und geschrieben werden
oder das ja dass diese schauspielerin
die sich jetzt beklagen dass die ja
schon auch gewusst haben dass ihre
eigene sexualität kapital ist dass sie
einsetzen konnten oder dann finden wir
überall das gleiche muster nämlich
menschliche bedürfnisse definieren die
spielregeln und frauen können dann noch
entscheiden ob sie sich wie sie sich
danach richten und ob sie das gratis
tool oder für geld und das ist eine
katastrophe das macht dann menge
menschen unglücklich auch außerhalb der
prostitution dass auch männer weil sie
auch bilder im kopf haben übrigens land
ein mann auch die dummen und auf die
ganzen jungen unterfangen lernen in der
prostitution oder zumindest bei den
frauen die ich kenne ziemlich schnell
den unterschied zwischen dem porno unter
realität und das ist oft sehr lehrreich
ja also ich könnte man für die
pornografie ja auch sagen das muss man
darf man nicht wörtlich nehmen genauso
wenig also wenn man den kindern comics
zeigt wissen kinder eigentlich dass man
nicht über eine klippe laufen kann oder
ist keine ahnung der stücke zerhackt
werden kann das stellen wir nicht in
frage bei pornos denken die leute
seltsamerweise das sei eins zu eins aber
ist dass ein so realistische mehr oder
weniger gute kunden und sie aber mit dem
ganz starken motto daherkommt wie in der
sexindustrie üblich sie will was er will
und sie macht was also über erotische
siehst du wort hier interessant weil
gerade als rein und vergewaltigungen an
sie haben die vergewaltigungs fantasie
bei frauen die schon freud beschrieben
hat kommt eben daher dass man da ist
diese guilty pleasures nicht ausleben
was wenn man da die kinderstube halten
kann es ganz schlimm findet aber es
fasziniert einen doch bei allen
entschuldigen das möchte ich gerne
psychologisch etwas korrigieren weil die
vergewaltigungs fantasie ist keine
hingabe fantasie der wunsch die frau
sich nicht erniedrigt zu werden sondern
das ist eine ganz wunderbare kontroll
fantasie weil die frau in ihrem kopf ja
alles kontrolliert würde gerne mit herrn
schreiber man noch über das thema
sprechen der einwilligung herrsche aber
sie haben ja lange über dieses thema
nachgedacht es gibt hier ein ganzes buch
auch über konzert über einwilligung und
das ist ja wirklich so einer der
kernfragen wenn es um prostitution geht
nämlich die frage wozu können wir
eigentlich freiwillig einwilligen was
heißt das überhaupt also wenn man das
buch von frau conrad ließ dann geht da
so beschrieben was in der prostitution
besonders oft nachgefragt wird die
verschiedenen taktiken dazu gehört zum
beispiel sperma ins gesicht der frau
spritzen analverkehr an allah faust fig
steht da erwarten also auch in ihren
passiert sowas dann absolut richtig aber
ich würde gerne ich würde gerne von
herrn sch aber wissen ist denn alles
worauf sich zwei menschen einigen gegen
geld oder nicht gegen geld worauf die
sich einigen auch in ordnung
moralisch ist nicht alles in ordnung
worauf man sich einlässt freiwilligen
lässt beispielsweise auf gewalt oder
ausbeutung um zwei dinge zu nennen würde
ich meinen die werden durch einwilligung
nicht richtig gemacht
allerdings ist es tatsächlich so
einwilligung spielt eine zentrale rolle
auch bei sexuellen austauschen
geschlechts austausch weil es alle
formen der nicht an gebilligten
sexualität sind natürlich graz verwerfen
und alle formen von gewalt die dazu zu
sexualität führen wir haben wir
vergewaltigung geredet vorhin ich finde
das steht außer diskussion klar ist das
moralisch zu verurteilen die frage ist
ist es prinzipiell ausgeschlossen dass
man freiwillig in sexuelle handlungen 1
1 belegt gegen geld es ist ihre meinung
nicht weiter ansicht nach nicht aus
meiner sicht hinzu
ich glaube auch dass es das ist aber wie
viel wir denn heraus ob etwas freiwillig
ist das eine freiwilligkeit die werte
von freundlichkeit ist schlicht und
einfach die dass man sagt sie ist nicht
erzwungen und es ist nicht unter
massivem druck
die verteidiger die wir ja genau den
bereichen haben massiver druck
also wenn wir jetzt die verschiedenen
studien herr anschauen auch die zahlen
aus der schweiz die man konsultieren
kann dann ist ein großteil der
prostitution hat tatsächlich zu tun mit
materiellen verhältnissen und die frage
ist was ist jetzt mit all den personen
aus osteuropa die zu uns kommen die
beispielsweise zu hause eine mutter
haben die pflegebedürftig ist man muss
diese kranken kosten bezahlen wir haben
vielleicht kinder man muss die
schulgelder bezahlen
die kommen hierher können hier sehr sehr
schnell geld verdienen in der
prostitution und natürlich kann man
irgendwie sagen die wählen das freilich
keine zwangsprostitution
aber es ist prostitution die resultiert
aus ungleichen verhältnisse nicht glaubt
so viel kann man sagen ist das
freiwillig ich würde sagen das ist
freiwillig ist deshalb nicht es ist
deshalb nicht unproblematisch weil die
verhältnisse in denen die menschen leben
das nicht unproblematisch sind natürlich
so sein wir wissen etwas dafür tun es
müsste etwas dafür getan werden was die
verhältnisse sich ändern aber ich würde
nicht von zwang reden viele leute müssen
irgendwelche jobs akzeptieren
jenseits jetzt der konstitution die
nicht unbedingt besonders attraktiv sind
weil sie einfach überleben müssen und da
würden wir auch nicht von zwang reden
gab die idee von zwang ist sind
gezwungen wird man wenn man wenn man nur
noch die wahl hat zwischen unzumutbaren
optionen und das glaube ich ist nicht so
schnell der fall also wenn man alle
kassen
ich würde sagen wenn man an einer kasse
im supermarkt arbeiten muss ist das
nicht zu haben
die von uns wer bin ich bin
verwöhnt in meinem job ich würde gerne
verstehen die sie auf solche fälle
blicken ist das für sie eine provokation
frauen zu haben die sagen ich mache mich
den job an der aldi kasse oder bei der
migros kasse
ich will lieber prostitution ist es eine
provokation für sie
oder würden sie beide sagen das glauben
die ihr gar nicht so recht weil
freiwilligkeit ist dass die ist ja immer
abhängig von den handlungs und
entscheidungsspielraum
ich habe zum einen und zum anderen
wissen wir eben auch dass frauen die in
die prostitution einsteigen viele davon
das ist für viele von ihnen auch eine so
was wie eine logische fortsetzung von
bisherigen lebenserfahrungen war also
wenn jemand in seiner kindheit
misshandlungen missbrauch gewalt oder
sehr viel vernachlässigung erfahren hat
dann ist der schritt zum beispiel in die
prostitution nicht so also denn dann
wird das auch dadurch erklärbar und die
frauen sagen aber in dem moment ja ich
mache das freiwillig und für mich ist
immer die frage
wir können ja nicht nur da sozusagen in
dem fall mit die post die freiheit der
prostituierten hochleben sondern wir
müssen doch auch schauen welche freiheit
welche wahlmöglichkeiten haben männer
und wir gehen und da ist freiheit gleich
wieder wegnehmen und sieht wieder nicht
über ihren körper bestimmen dürfen ich
kenne eine frau zum beispiel die auch
vergewaltigt wurde und sie sagt jetzt
habe ich wieder kontrolle darüber
und es sind bauern für sie weil sie die
bedingungen bestimmt natürlich macht sie
es niklas bereich aber auch das kann
eine art von therapeutische funktion
haben vor allem wenn diese frauen starke
frauen sind es gibt sehr viele die sich
für irgendwelche jobs hinscheiden auch
im künstlerischen bereich zum beispiel
aufgrund von von gründen die wir nicht
gut finden können das ist genau das was
ich eben gesagt habe und in dem und das
mag sein dass die frauen das erst mal
für sich ermächtigen ter leben weil sie
sagen diesmal entscheide ich diesmal
bekomme ich zumindest ein bisschen geld
für die sexualisierte oder sexuelle
gewalt
das problem sind ja die die folgen
würden gerne auch noch zu wort kommen
herrscher wachsen
möchte ich ein künstler noch hören wie
er ob das eine provokation ist und ich
habe keine antwort
diese problematischen aspekte die sie
diese diese methoden und diese
problematischen biografien die würde ich
gar nicht in zweifel ziehen
das wird wohl der fall sein die frage
ist nur was folgt jetzt eigentlich
daraus heißt es jetzt dass man mit einer
zusätzlichen kriminalisierung begegnen
mussten sagen wir wollen sie auf
erbschaften oder gegebenenfalls und dann
noch einmal dieser hinweis auf eines
international was die dort sagen dass er
hat mir eingeleuchtet nein was wir
machen müssen wir solche situationen ist
die wissen diese verhältnisse abschaffen
oder das müssen die rechte derer die da
drin sind stärken und sie schützen vor
zwar vor menschenhandel vor gewalt und
all die dinge
das ist und das ist der punkt also dass
das problematisches business das ist
klar aber dass man sagt das bringt man
am besten das dass das halt man indem
man einfach aus der welt
aber sind wir da nicht wieder beim team
am anfang ja erwähnt hat sie dass man
quasi sagt wozu ein verbot gut ist oder
nicht gut ist das können wir noch mal
diskutieren aber erstmal geht es ja
darum einen schritt zurück zu stehen und
zu fragen ist prostitution an sich
irgendwie moralisch gesehen automatisch
und sie meinen das ist ja ich hätte
gesagt ich glaube ich zur dynamik des
gesprächs gesagt obwohl ich ganz am
anfang gesagt habe ist eine tugend der
philosophie dass man diese genauigkeit
natürlich dass man wert darauf legt sind
und ich glaube wirklich nicht dass also
ich kann nur für mich sprechen
es braucht so viele zahlen und
erfahrungen und studien um oben zu sagen
nur weingesetz eine gesetzesänderung gut
ist oder nicht ich würde nie das sieht
sie ihre einfach sagen wollen doch das
muss sein oder nicht und wenn jetzt eine
dynamik entsteht in dieser plötzlich
irgendwie dieser seite des tisches so
darstellt also wir für ein verbot wären
dann ist es einfach nicht richtig
sondern ist ja ein philosophisches
gespräch und ich finde nicht nur muss
man eine unterscheidung machen zwischen
ich bin für ein verbot oder das
schwedische modell oder nicht sondern
sogar zusätzlich was ich gesagt habe
dass das man dafür sein kann dass diese
struktur in der prostitution eine eine
rolle spielt sexistisch ist das heißt
ungerecht frauen gegenüber in sowie die
gesellschaft im moment ist ohne dass man
einzelne frauen
dafür vorwürfe macht oder dass man sagt
man das habe ich verstanden warten sie
noch ganz kurz warum produziert
aber das heißt doch für sie eine welt in
der es keine prostitution mehr gibt ist
für sie eine bessere welt klarerweise
klarerweise aber das bedeutet nicht dass
mich alles habe ich verstanden auch
ihrer rechte selbst mir verboten wird
ministerin fehlerhaft um ihre frage
beruht sie meinen mann etwas moralisch
verwerflich ist
ihr müsst es verboten hier ist doch klar
das ist moralisch an zwei vorbei ist ist
doch der witz an der sache natürlich ist
mir klar dass es versucht das was ich
tue es gib mir doch leider ist nicht das
ist warum habe ich gar keine fixe
meinung war ich meine besten provokant
ich meine lenin hat gesagt irgendwann
wird es sechs sein wie das trinken eines
glases milch das wünsche ich mir nicht
viele dinge erledigen wollte aber bin
ich aber es ist doch so dass wenn man
jetzt sagt das was was moralisch
problematische verboten da müsste man
erst mal also fleischkonsum auto fahren
also wir können wir die liste wäre ja
aber wir selber einer liberalen
gesellschaft wo die menschen die
freiheit haben auch um gewalt zu tun
solange sind damit keine freiheit eines
anderen gefährden frage stellen
zu dieser diagnose wenn wir jetzt
wirklich von prostitution reden und
nicht von den missbrauchsfällen die
natürlich klar weiß verurteilt werden
müssten gewalt vergewaltigung als dass
man sie gar nicht so diskutieren wenn
wir einfach davon reden jetzt von
käuflichem sex was macht das moralisch
falsch habe ich fragen was genau ist das
ich glaube dass man das nicht verkaufen
darf
dass man aber andere die ja rufen darf
aber das nicht in einer in einer
struktur in der es diese macht nicht in
eine struktur ist das als solches das
wirklich das ist man ja als solche nicht
juckt das klar wir haben wir wissen
nicht wer vergewaltigung reden wir über
menschen haben über zwangspausen die
zwischen das weiß ich es
sehen und dass noch mehr leute ich sehe
den punkt ich weiß nicht was da ist aber
was soll ich das nicht in ordnung
ich denke wenn wir wenn wir uns
irgendwie eine hypothetische
gesellschaft vorstellen könnten in der
es das nicht gibt keine macht
unterschiede uns wirklich keine zwischen
also nicht zwischen männern und frauen
nicht rassen und nicht einkommen oder
wasser oder reichtum und dann würden
zwei personen und und es wäre auch die
gesamte struktur der sexualität wäre
symmetrischer und wäre nicht geprägt von
unseren vorstellungen so dass das
wirklich ein ein spiel auf augenhöhe
wäre wenn dann eine person einer anderer
geld für sechs ansehen hydrobar ist die
sich zur verfügung stellen vielleicht
das noch diesen die norton nicht aus
das ist nicht mal nicht automatisch dass
die zeit dass er das folglich dann geht
es auch
erklären sie doch diesen punkt warum
warum ist der vergleich mit dem
korbacher die frage wer der cowboy
unproblematisch waren unsere
gesellschaft als sexistisch gegen frauen
würden sie sagen
august kein problem sie sagen der klage
ja ich weiß da müsste man sich jetzt
wieder die strukturen
nein denn wenn das mit dem call boy wenn
die frage systematisch gemeint ist dann
dürften frauen ja mit frauen auch wenn
weihnachtsfest so gut wenn wir jetzt
sehen wir schon bei den fiesen fragen
und beim körper dann frage ich jetzt
sagen wir mal zurück was wäre zum
beispiel herrscht aber sie haben zwei
söhne wenn einer ihres sohnes kommen wir
den sagen papa ich bin callboy aus wenn
sie sagen versucht anfrage
natürlich werden die tiere und würde
natürlich rückfragen stellen
ich meine ich habe nicht gesagt dass es
irgendwie ich mir stelle mir das nicht
aus den idealen als idealen job vor ich
würde gern fragen gibt es keine angst
keine alternative gefunden
wir reden jetzt ja gut leben vielleicht
vielleicht ist das zu wenig gefragt nur
wenn wir diskutieren ist es moralisch
was nicht in ordnung möglich gewissen
moralischen vorwurf machen das wär's ja
also ich meine kann eben vielleicht
sagen dass das nicht die klügste
entscheidung ich würde ihn auch andere
jobs übrigens abraten
es gibt auch andere jobs die die ich
nicht die kriegs entscheidung für nicht
zu welchen taten wissenschaftlicher wäre
gut
dieser welt wo das sind weiter das
wollten wir dann aber es gibt natürlich
auch ein generelles problem mit den
eltern oder mit den angehörigen also in
berlin organisiert ziemlich stammtische
für sexarbeiter und ihre angehörigen
weil auch angehörigen stigmatisiert
beispielsweise der partner dem wird
entweder gesagt du hast deine frau nicht
außer kontrolle sagt einmal bescheid
oder es wird gesagt du bist ihr zuhälter
und der kann sich auch nirgendwo outen
und dass diese stigmatisierung dass man
isoliert ist man traut sie das nichts zu
erzählen
man traut sich dann noch nicht über
probleme zu reden weil die antwort immer
nur ist warum machst du das und mache
ich dann schmutzig führt also wenn man
das machen sie weil es spaß macht was
großartig ist weil es eine
intellektuelle herausforderung weil ich
den menschen eine weiß kennenlerne die
ich sonst nicht kennen lerne weil ich
damit mehr geld verdienen als mit
geistiger arbeit die welt 250 euro pro
text ist glaub es zählt nicht
und ich hatte einmal eine lesung aus
einem roman projekt und ein date am
selben abend für die lesung bekam ich
irgendwie 50 euro und ein glas wasser
für das date bekam ich 1000 euro 50 euro
taxi geld und wer gutes essen dem tag
war es als würde irgendwie deutschlands
zu mir sagen alles was du denkst ist
nicht so wertvoll wie dein arsch damit
könnte überlegen ob man kunst besser
bezahlt ob man generell besser andere
jobs besser bezahlt die junge menschen
akademiker gerade machen können
aber ich meine das ist einfach das ist
vor allem dicke bretter und wenn man
arbeitsbedingungen wirklich pragmatisch
verbessern wir was nötig ist es
unbedingt nötig ist wenn man diesen
menschen helfen will dann gibt es zwei
dinge erstens die stigmatisierung
beseitigen offen darüber reden keine
verbote und zweitens natürlich
sozialpolitik solidarität unter sechs
arbeitern das fördern von
berufsverbänden bei der stigmatisierung
bin ich absolut bei ihnen dass das
endlich aufhören muss und ich finde es
eine katastrophe dass diese jahrhunderte
lange historische schmutzkampagne nur an
frauen hängen geblieben ist während der
mann ganz unbehelligt von seiner
bürgerlichen welt ins rotlicht-milieu
und wieder zurückgehen kann aber das
genau ist das was ich so kritisiere wir
reden zu wenig
dann lassen sie uns über die männer
sprechen das würde ich gerne tun indem
ihr kurz alice schwarzer zu hören alles
schwarze sagt nämlich wir wissen ja ein
stück weit sehr genau dass das verbot
möglicherweise negative konsequenzen
haben wird für die prostituierten selber
aber was das mit den männern macht das
müssen wir uns auch mal überlegen alice
schwarzer war vor vier jahren bei uns zu
gast er kurz zu wenn der opposition
reden reden wir nicht nur über die
frauen in der prostitution die direkt
betroffen sind und die männer gehen ja
auch unrecht getan wird junge männer die
in eine welt hinein wachsen wo man ihm
sagt du bist kein problem lg zu den
nächsten tag macht die bandbreite hirsch
ein schuss was richten wir denn an in
den köpfen von frauen im männern wenn
wir das verharmlosen wenn wir männer
möglich machen auszuweichen
auch sexualität wieder abzutrennen vom
gefühl abzutrennen von beziehung wie
kommen denn diese frau nach hause
nicht nur eventuell mit aids weil zu
nehmen wollen die männer ohne kondome
nicht sondern sie kommen auch mit einer
vorstellung der sexualität nach hause
die natürlich jede beziehung
überschattet der film ist ja ich bin ich
bin mit einem punkt einverstanden mit
einem nicht oder ich glaube aus meiner
perspektive ist nicht unbedingt die die
ablösung von gefühl und sexualität das
moralische problem
sonst müsste man vielleicht auch gegen
one-night-stands sein und das sehe ich
jetzt wenn das wenn das einvernehmlich
ist das sehe ich nicht dass man da ein
moralisches argument das nicht sehr
konservativ ist konstruieren könnte also
dass da würde ich dir nicht denn denn
den gleichen schwerpunkt wählen wie vor
schwarze aber ich würde sicher sagen
natürlich dass der schwerpunkt auf die
männer also dass man schaut was eben
auch mit den männern passiert
eine zentrale ist ich habe das auch
nachgeschaut so dass einer meiner
lieblings philosophen john stuart mill
ich habe sogar ihr buch mit darüber
jahren ein buch geschrieben und der
sagte dina wie die prostitution musste
antreten so zu seiner mission über eine
gesetzesänderung im bereich der
prostitution 18 71 100 da schon zum zum
erstaunen von allen sich geweigert
einfach nur
die schuld am ganzen den frauen zu geben
hat den schwerpunkt auf die auf die
männer gelegt und hat auch gesagt dass
die die bilder von frauen und männer
neben geschichten sind dass das
ideologisch ist dieses dampfkessel
modell eine geschichte ist die wir uns
selbst erzählen und das wäre nicht
herausfinden können wie wir miteinander
umgehen könnten
unter den gegebenen verheilt ist wenn
wir denken die frauen und männer bleibt
einfach so wie sie jetzt hier sind es
tut mir echt weh wie sie hier irgendwie
sich selbst mit castagna es ist fast
schon ein schulisches beispiel also ich
meine ich habe nie die männer
kennengelernt wir uns verschiedene und
das einmal mit einer erfahrung macht ist
es höchst individuell es gibt ja auch
nicht die frauen ansonsten werden die
online gleich also ich kann nur für den
männern sprechen die ich kennenlerne
es gibt auch unterschiede von den
männern im bordell und dem einem high
class bereich oder den männern ich sonst
kennenlernen ich weiß nur eins ich bin
bleibt beim privaten sektor als günstig
in berlin sehr ausgiebig hatte nie so
gut behandelt worden die bei einem
escort vielleicht weil ich geld gekostet
habe oder weil die männer bildeten
kultivierter man aber ich finde es
einfach irgendwie falsch
von alice schwarzer ist es für männer
hast damit spielt und uns meine sie
machen damit man jetzt einfach ungerecht
ich finde es auch unmöglich dass meine
kunden die ich sehr schätze die seit
jahren treffe das über die so geredet
wird weil auch unsere kunden des
stigmatisiert und niemand wo das
passiert und kunden so steht dieses
darüber nicht sprechen können fehlt eine
hälfte der debatte aber es muss auch
wirklich sein als man sagen zu dürfen
wie perikles das über seine aspasia
sagte ja ich habe eine eta oder eine
kurtisane konsumiert und ich habe mit
ihr geschlafen ich habe geld gegeben wir
haben es gut verstanden wie man auch
sagen kann dass man dass man im theater
war oder dass man einem guten restaurant
was ist doch nicht verwerflich ist und
wenn ein mann eine kurtisane schlecht
behandelt oder eine straßen
prostituierte auch das ist ein problem
aber sagen dass alle männer uns
eigentlich waren es ist richtig
gesagt ich spreche von von normen und
rollen die reden von den männern ich
spreche von den
männlichkeitsvorstellungen normen
rollenbildern an den männer gemessen
wird wir haben in der gesellschaft
man man man kennt zum beispiel
ausdrucksweisen wie ein prominenter
hinein schweizer vor einigen jahren
gesagt wer mit 34 noch nie für sex
bezahlt hat hat ja auch nicht richtig
gelebt er malte man unbedingt mal man ja
aber das ist doch damit sind damit sind
männer gemeint ist eindeutig näher
gemacht
und das sind männliche wenn man dass das
sind die männlichkeit ideale die
beeinflusst sind von solchen dingen das
heißt nicht dass sich die männer alle
daran halten
aber es gibt eine vorstellung oder es
gibt vorstellungen das kann verschieden
sein was ein richtiger mann ist was ein
mann männlicher macht das ein mann
weniger menschlich macht und die prägen
uns also ich habe wir tun so als ob wir
sexualität bis zur unkenntlichkeit
verdinglichung können damit habe ich als
psychologe naturgemäß ein problem weil
sexualität ist eine sehr intime form der
kommunikation eine kommunikation in der
menschen sich nahe kommen können
das ist etwas was in der prostitution
diese diese intime kommunikation soll da
ja gar nicht stattfindet sondern es
dadurch stattfinden dass der mann
bestimmt was passiert das ist das wesen
der prostitution
also nein das habe ich das wesen der
prostitution ist gibt es aber es mag es
auch sicherlich aber ich finde das wäre
doch wichtiger dass wir schauen was ist
das was männer warum gehen männer zu
prostituierten wir leben wir heute in
einer welt wo wir eigentlich über kinder
und was weiß ich was jederzeit mit
jeweils einer situation wie sie sich
selber abschaffen weil dem grunde
genommen jederzeit gelegenheit 6 und
sowie so organisieren dass ohne das geld
in chile war es muss einen unterschied
sein und die probleme bestehen ja nicht
nur in der prostitution sondern die
probleme entstehen ja auch in der die
bestehen ja auch in der öffentlichkeit
wenn wir zb in deutschland ist
vergewaltigung in der ehe es seit 1997
ein straftatbestand das müssen uns mal
vorstellen es ist
jetzt sichern aber da sehen wir nämlich
genau dieses was ich vorher schon gesagt
hat der mann hat ein gesetzlich
verbrieftes recht auf seine sexualität
ist und das ist ein problem lassen sie
nicht an dieser stelle doch mal noch
einen schritt weiter gehen einmal
weggehen von 1000 frauen das sind männer
und dieses für männer wie für frauen
und weil einfach fragen was passiert
eigentlich wenn wir für sex bezahlen
egal ob männer frauen frauen männer
man könnte ja sagen wer zahlt der
befiehlt und das ideal will ich sage
jetzt trotzdem idealbild von sexualität
könnte ja sowas sein wie es geht um ein
aushandeln
ein gemeinsames sich befriedigend ein
gemeinsames sich aneinander erfreuen
und wenn gilt der zahlt der befiehlt
dann haben wir ja sofort dieses
machtgefälle mit drin
würden sie jetzt haben das ist einfach
eine andere form der sexualität oder
besteht darin schon eine gewisse
schwierigkeit weil es vielleicht auch
einfach sehr viel einfacher es war das
andere das aushandeln ich ja immer auch
sehr anstrengend vielleicht hört sich
das dann sind vielleicht ein bisschen
sehr romantisch und ich weiß es auch
nicht so ist aber ich finde es ist auch
ein problem
man sieht es an bord aushandeln oder
kürzlich hat als verteidigung der
prostitution sehen dass wir auch
außerhalb von prostitution aushandeln im
gegenteil es ist halt teil desselben
modells und das ist kein schönes modell
warum sind wir sexualität auch
vielleicht auch als etwas wo zwei
personen einander brauchen um sich
selbst zu befriedigen das ist nicht ganz
fair
kollektives verständnis von sexualität
das bitte das nicht wie man freut sich
gemeinsam oder warum verstehen wir das
nicht mehr am modell das sich gemeinsam
freuen und gemeinsam glücklich sein wo
krieg laviert ich bin jetzt ich einfach
die andere person und jander person
benutzt mich im besten fall oder nur
einseitig im schlechteren fall sondern
es ist ein anderes modell und und je
mehr wir dieses modell diese ökonomische
modelle sexualität auch außerhalb der
prostitution an finden desto schlechter
das nicht umso besser für die
prostitution sondern um so schlecht da
für unsere sexualität kann hat die er
definiert als einen vertrag über den
wechselseitigen gebraucht der
geschlechtsorgane
mann kann aber auch nicht verheiratet
gut wir sind am ende dieses stammtisches
wir haben über viel gestritten eine
lösung gefunden haben hier nicht dass
wir auch nicht zu erwarten bei einem so
schwierigen thema virgin drossel sagte
einmal viele menschen würden eher
sterben als dass sie denken würden
tatsächlich tun sie das auch wir
versuchen die logischen stammtisch den
gegenbeweis anzutreten und insofern
bedanke ich mich ganz herzlich für das
mitdenken frau bald herr schaber frau
kohn ratsherr künstler vielen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und auch ihnen zu hause ganz herzlichen
dank für das interesse nächste woche
spricht bossard mit dem star architekten
jacques herzog über gute architektur und
über das gute leben
ihnen allen eine gute woche denken sie
weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]